[intense music]
The bee pupa are
stored at the bottom.
So to collect them, I have
to cut through the hive.
[buzzing]
They just pierced that comb,
and honey is just dripping out.
I catch it with my
bamboo container.
I'm just trying to get as
much of that honey as I can.
My final job, to
reach even higher
and scrape the
honeycomb from the rock.
Oh, my god.
I'm just covered
in honey and bees,
and I'm sticky everywhere.
I think we've gotten
all that we can get.
OK.
That's getting the
honey the hard way.
Woo!
My hands just ache
from being stung.
But this whole thing
is just solid honey.
And this, the bottom part of
the comb is wax and pupae.
None of this stuff is
going to go to waste.
We have a taste of our prize.
I am just a sticky mess, but--
[non-english speech]
The sweetness of this
honey is, like, peach flavor.
Like, I never had
honey like this at all.
Mmm.